Присіли, присіли!
Ось вам близько. Менше, ніж 500 метрів.
Зруйновані будинки, знищена інфраструктура і постійні обстріли мінометами,
артилерією та важким озброєнням - так живе Бахмут останні п’ять місяців.
Я не знаю, як там мій дім.
Ось, і так постійно.
Колись переважно тилове місто перетворилося на місце активних бойових дій.
Після того, як російські війська захопили Сєвєродонецьк та Лисичанськ,
вони почали інтенсивно наступати на Бахмут, не шкодуючи ані зброї, ані людей.
Ми розуміємо, що Бахмут потрібен Путіну як подарунок до Нового року,
і саме тому вони зараз тут створили таке криваве місиво.
Через кровопролитні бої з обох сторін битву за Бахмут вже називають "бахмутською м’ясорубкою".
Те, що це місто протягом місяців залишається центром бойових дій,
з оперативної та військової точки зору на сьогоднішній день не зовсім зрозуміло.
Звісно, постає питання: чому кілька місяців маленьке місто
та його околиці так захищають? За що проливається стільки крові
- і військових, і бідних мирних жителів? У мене є лише одне пояснення:
справа в неймовірній символічній важливості Бахмута
для подальшого ходу бойових дій і успіху обох сторін.
Австрійський генерал Файхтінґер пояснює цю символічність тим,
що Україна дає зрозуміти, що може не лише відстояти власні території,
а й повернути їх назад. Натомість російська армія хоче продемонструвати,
що може завоювати будь-які території, які вважатиме за потрібне, будь-якою ціною.
І є ще третій аспект, який не можна недооцінювати: це угруповання ПВК Вагнера.
Вони беруть участь у боях за Бахмут дуже активно й інтенсивно, прагнучи,
з одного боку, продемонструвати Україні, що вони сильніші за регулярні російські війська,
а з іншого - показати політичному керівництву Росії, що саме вони -
найпотужніша зброя, найсильніший козир у цій боротьбі.
Тому Кремлю після низки поразок на харківському та херсонському напрямках
будь-що потрібна стратегічна перемога. Для цього вони не лише кидають в бій
велику кількість мобілізованих, а й змінили тактику. За даними британської розвідки,
російське військове угруповання "Вагнер" розробило наступальну тактику,
щоб використати погано навчених завербованих засуджених.
Окремим бійцям, ймовірно, видають смартфони чи планшети,
на яких позначено вісь просування та ціль нападу, накладені на комерційні
супутникові зображення. А командири, швидше за все, залишаються в укритті
і віддають накази по рації, отримуючи інформацію з безпілотників.
Окремим частинам і частинам наказано йти заздалегідь запланованим маршрутом,
часто з вогнем, але рідше з бронетехнікою. Оперативники Вагнера,
які відхиляються від своїх маршрутів штурму без дозволу, ймовірно,
опинилися під загрозою розстрілу. Ця жорстока тактика спрямована на збереження
рідкісних активів Вагнера у вигляді досвідчених командирів
і бронетехніки за рахунок більш доступних засуджених-новобранців,
яких організація оцінює як витратний матеріал.
Вони більше не атакують масштабно по всьому фронту, а намагаються просуватися
меншими групами. Це тактика своєрідних шпилькових уколів,
яка позбавляє сторону, що обороняється, можливості розгорнути сили
для масованого удару, а змушує розподіляти їх. А розподіл військових сил -
це завжди дуже небезпечний момент у будь-якому бою. Це означає, що перед ЗСУ
стоїть завдання зберегти згуртованість оборонних підрозділів,
а не потрапити на тактичні хитрощі противника, наприклад,
перекинувши сили не на ту ділянку фронту, де буде завдано основного удару,
а за три-п'ять кілометрів від нього.
За словами військового журналіста Юрія Бутусова, нова тактика - це тактика
повзучого піхотного наступу. Таку раніше використовували саме
українські військові у перший період війни.
В перший період війни саме українська армія проводила такий позиційний
піхотний наступ, реалізовувала тактику піхотної війни.
Натомість росіяни намагалися діяти зосередженими зусиллями,
такими з’єднаннями, частинами бронетанкових військ, намагалися використати
для проривів передусім бронетехніку та артилерію. На першому етапі бронетехніку,
на другому етапі артилерійський наступ, тобто артилерію.
Зараз закінчилися у Росії всі запаси боєприпасів, великі проблеми у них тепер
навіть з відновленням артилерійських стволів, немає такої кількості боєприпасів,
знищена більша частина нової бронетехніки, яку вони тепер не можуть відновити.
Тому росіяни зробили ставку теж на піхотну війну.
Через такий наступ великими військами піхоти на широкому фронті
російські війська несуть великі втрати. Але продовжують шукати слабкі місця
в обороні ЗСУ і намагатися просуватися на 100-200 метрів.
Напряму вони не знають, де ми знаходимося, але вони прощупують сектором.
Саме місто є важливим не лише для Росії, а й для України.
Бахмут - стратегічно важливе місто на Донбасі і дуже зручний рубіж для оборони,
який знаходиться на гряді висот. А ще - важливий комунікаційний вузол.
Якщо Росія його захопить - це може стати зручним плацдармом
для наступу на решту територій Донецької області.
Якщо уявити собі, що противник захопив би Бахмут, то довелося б відходити
з цілої гряди, з цілого району оборони. Нам довелося би одночасно залишити міста Соледар
і Сіверськ, і значну низку сіл. Тобто це значно покращило б стратегічне положення ворога
і дозволило б йому в дуже зручних умовах просуватися далі
на Слов’янсько-Краматорський вузол. А ця агломерація, ці міста - це фактично ворота,
ключ до Донбасу. Тобто вони знаходяться в такому місці, яке з’єднує Слобожанщину і Донбас.
Тому, звичайно, для нас стратегічно це дуже важливе,
принципове питання: не допустити ворога до Бахмута.
Російська армія рішуче намагається перемогти у цій битві.
Та українські війська мають зручні для оборони позиції і здатні зупинити противника,
вважають закордонні експерти.
Я б не назвав ситуацію критичною, тому що українська армія не загрузла в обороні.
Навпаки, вона, як і раніше, намагається перейти у наступ. І не лише у Бахмуті,
а й у сусідньому регіоні, де Україна неодноразово намагалася відвоювати свої території.
Іншими словами, це в жодному разі не криза. Це дуже складна ситуація.
У випадку з Бахмутом ідеться про те, хто здобуде перемогу.
Її високе символічне значення є важливим,
але не вирішальним чинником для перебігу всієї війни.
У Бахмуті щоденно гинуть не лише військові, а й цивільні.
За неофіційними даними, зараз у Бахмуті живе від 10 до 15 тисяч людей.
Раніше місцеве населення налічувало 70 тисяч.
Ті, хто залишився, виживають, як можуть, розповідає журналістка Ольга Кириленко,
яка нещодавно повернулася з міста.
Люди палять у дворах багаття, у тих, у кого є буржуйки, гріються буржуйками.
У кого немає, то роблять такі ніби саморобні плити з цегли і з таких металевих пластів,
і гріють там собі воду для чаю або навіть варять супи.
Здебільшого люди збираються такими купками. Тобто весь двір збирається
навколо однієї плити і так готує собі їсти.
Я вийшла підігріти суп і чай. Пічки у нас немає, буржуйки нам не дають, не везуть.
Доводиться отаку домашню плитку робити і займатися.
Погано живемо, пенсії маленькі, тому ми тут і залишилися.
От у нього тисяча пенсії, у мені 2500. Як можна їхати кудись з такими грошима?..
Багато мостів зруйновані, світла і зв’язку немає,
а за гуманітарною допомогою треба йти у центр міста.
Район "М’ясокомбінат". Переправи всі у нас зруйновані.
Є пенсіонери, є просто старенькі люди.
Дійти в місто - нереально. Йдуть і по коліна в багнюці.
І через кладочку, там місток такий старий-старий, що ледве-ледве люди перебираються.
Наш район вважається сірою зоною. У нас вже ні швидка допомога,
ні пожежна не приїжджає. Хліб також до нас ніхто не привозить.
Виживаємо, хто як може.
А через морози температура в будинках опускається майже до нуля.
Збираємо дрова. Коли осколки летіли, позрубували гілки ці.
Ми їх збираємо і обігріваємося. Якось так, нічого страшного.
Буває, що вода замерзає. Але ми сильні.
У кімнаті +2. Але нічого, ми витримаємо, ми сильні.
Багато місцевих не хоче виїжджати з рідного міста. Одна з таких Світлана,
яка не лише не занепадає духом, але й зігріває українських військових
- варить для них чай і каву.
Ми за Збройні сили України, ми за свою любу Україну, рідну.
Ми її ніколи не залишимо, нашу рідну землю.